the United Nations set out to help the
world's poorest people through the
Millennium Development Goals the eight
ambitious goals have mobilized the
international community to reduce
inequality improve overall health and
protect the environment all by December
31st 2015 so how much progress has been
made well global poverty has fallen but
progress on the goals has been uneven
especially in Africa aj+ has created an
interactive infographic that measures
the progress of participating countries
it tracks nine different key measures
associated with the goals check out our
aj+ website to explore and learn more
back in two thousand the UN created the
Millennium Development Goals in an
effort to improve life in developing
regions by 2015